You do think that what's your opinion about like older animate, uh,
older animate versus like newer digitized anime?
Oh yeah. Um, well, digital mission, uh,
is, uh,
you can get quicker because we can walk at your place and the send by mail or
the, the, the datas, it's not paper. You don't have to scan it. Uh,
but, uh, uh, the program of a Steeler and an emission industry,
they must have, like I said, [inaudible], uh,
animation director. Most of them are on paper. So, because
they've been in the industry for so long, so long and you date, they would like to learn some digital
and mentioned budget. Don't have the time of, yeah, we'll say Don [inaudible]
10 years and dies. Or.
I learned animation on paper. I won't die.
Some of my senpai have tried to learn a digital emission,
but he was too much stress is that you have a pain and stomach to go to.
Must be God,
it's horrible basis. I have to love that. So.
Uh, also, yeah, more so me, I'm doing digital. Yeah.
And so I'm doing my layout in digital, so, but if the second have to check it,
put correction, they have to print it and write. So yeah.
But I'm doing it, then fax it back to you. Right.
So that was a joke. That's a joke.
I was joking because yeah. They have a paper,
none of that, sorry. [inaudible].
Uh, by your data and to, for me to doing it digitally. So yeah.
So most amazing man. Now, most of the enriching, uh, uh, digital,
but, uh, it depends. Uh, so digital and paper are a bit, uh,
I think more, in fact, a veterans, a good animators,
that's still on paper and right nowadays some young are more on digital, but,
uh, the program is software. You have to pay it. And, um,
most of the such software expensive commercial licenses are very expensive
and also, you know,
how much animators have paid so they can say, yeah,
he's good. Softer, like TV pain too, but too expensive. So,
uh, yeah, so.
I can't,
I can't believe the software's like too expensive for the people who are going
to use it for the people who are going to use the software,
what he was designed to do. Sorry, man, we want to pay you more,
but Photoshop is like 600 bucks a month.
So it's kind of expensive fun. Now, young animators.
Are walking on blender because Brenda is free, free,
and you can do 3d and 2d animation at the same time. And I see.
So I thought that was just a meme. So, so people in the army industry,
Archer using blender.
Uh, some of them not to everybody, but uh, uh.
Cause it's like a meme now whenever we see something bad, that is like, Oh,
this looks like it was animated in blender. Think wasn't any,
any reality to that
slowly, closest blender.
Yeah. I, in fact it was just stuff doesn't um, it doesn't the big point. Uh,
if you put it, uh, has a still on like a paper. Yeah.
Because what's the question would be on paper, on digital,
but because each you, if it's on G Pega,
every soft can open a G big. Yeah. Yeah.
I am curious being an animator because like we do,
we do anime videos on YouTube and talk about anime.
And as someone who watches anime as a job, I cannot like,
I still enjoy anime, but I can't enjoy anime the same way I used to as a kid,
as someone who actually works on anime,
has it changed your view of anime at all and how you watch it and everything
like that.
Actuary I'm from some of my friends nowadays watch less and less
animation and going into are more critics. Right.
Right, right. But those tend to happen. Yeah.
I can't imagine an animator casually sitting down to watch it.
I can't wait for my favorite season of seven deadly sins.
What did you think about that?
Sorry. I just watched the first season, so.
Okay. Okay. Oh, have you seen pictures of season.
Three?
Do I need to ask your opinion or is it obvious? Yeah.
I understand your feelings.